continúa la fiesta de las calles de
londres en ese tercer día de
celebraciones del jubileo de platino de
la fiesta de la reina isabel 2ª como
ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas cada
vez más llegan más personas aquí a las
afueras del palacio de pekín amén está
la avenida de molt para intentar ver así
sea por unos segundos a una mujer que ha
sido protagonista de nuestra historia
de hecho también se está terminando toda
la logística para el gran concierto que
será esta noche que reunirá a 22 mil
invitados entre ellos trabajadores del
sistema nacional de salud británico en
eses miembros del público que han tenido
que reclamar ganarse las boletas desde
hace varias semanas veremos en escena a
grandes de la música como al tenor
italiano andrea bocelli rod stewart
alicia keys ryan ross y también el
regreso de queens ahora que la reina
isabel no ha participado en muchos de
los eventos planeados para este jubileo
de platino no se tenía confirmado que
fuera asistir pero ya es un hecho que no
va a asistir a varios es inevitable
pensar en el futuro de la monarquía
británica la reina isabel muy a su
manera con la presencia cada vez más
notoria del príncipe william el segundo
en la línea de sucesión al trono
británico y también de su hijo carlos
desempeñando cada vez más labores más
importantes nos está mostrando que sigue
la tradición que la familia real ese es
el futuro que nos espera y por ello
hemos hablado con miembros del público
sobre cómo se imaginan el futuro de
justamente la monarquía británica
queen es un night in house y creo que la
gente absolutamente adorada la familia
real la reina es increíble
de verse como a cuidado de todo el país
se ha dedicado al servicio a la gente y
todos la aman y respetan
creo que su familia william y kate son
perfectos absolutamente los adoro estoy
segura de que carlos será un gran rey
cuando sea su turno
este domingo el último día de las
celebraciones del jubileo de platino se
tiene preparado un desfile que será
seguramente muy impresionante porque
además pasará por esta avenida de moll
que termina en el palacio de buckingham
un carruaje dorado que tiene 260 años de
historia pero además está convocando a
miembros del público para que hagan
almuerzos colectivos se prevé que
millones y millones de personas
aprovecharán esta fiesta para compartir
entre familias entre vecinos y también
será la oportunidad muy seguramente se
espera para que la reina isabel aparezca
nuevamente en el balcón del palacio de
buckingham acompáñenos aquí en france24
en español para todos los detalles